it's the holiday season we're feeling
festive and celebrating our favorite man
in bachelor nation it's time for roses
and roses a god bless us everyone god
bless us everyone hi everybody i'm
lauren zima Merry Christmas if you don't
celebrate Christmas
happy holidays but today is literally
Christmas can you tell
can you tell can you tell can you tell
can you tell
oh I hope that all of you are
celebrating with your loved ones your
family your friends I wanted to put
together my ideal Christmas for you on
roses and Rosie today so it is a lot of
empty Solo cups hope you're having some
eggnog and some Mead Mead wine what's a
Christmas wine roses are Christmas wine
it's year round I've said it before you
know what I did I put my rose a in a cup
with little gold rim so now it's
Christmassy I also have presents that
have nothing in them because I Amazon
Prime everything to befall save time for
yourselves I also have cookies and milk
because I love cookies but the milk is
Rosie
[Music]
all right everyone seriously there is
only one way that we could think of to
appropriately celebrate Christmas in
perfect bachelor fashion and that is by
celebrating with the most constant
figure in our bachelor nation lives
Chris Harrison here's the thing we
always have the flavor of the month you
know I mean you know how it goes
bachelors and bachelorettes may come and
go but Chris Harrison stays I love where
it goes and so here we are to highlight
our favorite Chris Harrison moments of
2018
it's Merry Christmas everybody what the
hell happened and look at how hardcore
I've gone into celebration
I am wearing Chris Harrison earrings now
look did I get these for free yes was I
sent them by someone so I didn't have to
go out and buy them again yes but again
it's the thought that counts and I
thought to put him on I thought to dig
through my desk and find them moving a
rose a bottle moving an empty rose a
bottle moving and I found anyway
alright everybody drink every time you
feel the holiday spirit or you feel the
spirit of Chris Harrison that was weird
the way I worded that what does that
mean please drink responsibly it's the
holidays we are celebrating the nine
best Chris Harrison moments of 2018
number nine it's appropriately wintery
Chris Harrison's Bachelor Winter Games
sit down with Ben Higgins so Chris
Harrison one of the reasons we love him
man oh man can he get that tears out of
people it's gut-wrenching
it's absolutely gut-wrenching that Chris
Harrison sit down I want more of those
on the show let him sit the people down
wonder if he does that it's such a weird
thing to do come on
come sit don't ever sit down next to
someone if they're doing this to you hot
tip for the new year anyway but do you
think there's anyone better than Chris
Harrison at getting tears from someone
to sit down maybe Barbara Walters I will
try not to but I can't guarantee you but
she's not on The Bachelor Barbara
Walters for Bachelorette I watched that
show
whoo okay number eight Christian do
dramatics attempts ending a new comedy
it's about having a good time
drink every time Chris Harrison and Fred
Willard made you laugh when they were
comedic Lee announcing the sporting
event and we have just a random girl
who's walked up as well
[Applause]
did you know Chris Harrison used to be a
sports announcer in Oklahoma drink
during the entirety of this old clip and
now News 9 sports with Chris Harrison
good afternoon last night's Game five of
the World Series a rematch from Game one
the veteran Orel Hershiser on the mound
for Cleveland
while the Marlins went with humid rookie
look to long sports take a long time
anyway
oh god football football takes a long
time to people watch football Christmas
airs it over so do the washing anything
Zenith JC s random
football time is like in paradox of time
you guys it's like oh we're 40 minutes
left
just kidding at 6 hours well we have two
minutes left
just kidding it's 40 minutes [ __ ]
nightmare I do the theater anyway okay
number seven we're moving on to the
Bachelorette Chris Harrison talking to
Colton Underwood about going to the
fantasy suites with Becca kufran next
week this fantasy suites write Chris's
face said it all drink to that face
number six in our Merry Christmas
moments
when I interviewed Chris after the men
tell all and he summarized it up as
Zoolander what word would you use to
describe these men Zoolander I feel like
we went full Zoolander tonight I'm
pretty sure there's a lot more to life
than being really really good-looking I
think we had a faceoff in a walk-off in
the middle of my show number five by the
way another moment from myself shames
blood when he called me out I've never
shown this to you guys but I always go
to Mexico to interview everybody before
Paradise starts and I sat down with
Chris and I don't want to shock you but
when I have notes for an interview
they're mostly scribbles and he called
me out of what I had written on my card
it's just a card and it says words like
scandal cast drama I'm like oh I should
ask about the scandal the cast the drama
you barely have anything written down I
have tons of important words you
literally have like 10 words this is the
Pulitzer okay I smell Emmy nobody nobody
ever asked to borrow my notes in college
whatever every master's degree oh I just
got Roseanne my own I said I had a
master's degree learn how to use dishes
Lauren number four when he admitted to
me in that same interview that he wasn't
sure if paradise would come back there
definitely was a time when I thought the
show might not come back I mean any show
you know as we just learned in recent
history you are you're one catastrophic
event away from being on that makes me
so grateful every day here's the thing
Chris Harrison is honest that's why I
love interviewing him he tells it like
it is he gives his true assessment of
things he teases what's to come in the
season without revealing too much but it
gives you something and Chris was honest
about everything that happened after the
scandal when the show returned this year
for season 5 of paradise he said he you
know looking back wasn't sure it would
come back but it did number three
let's drink to a Chris Harrison moment
that he always delivers on his fashion
here's to all the linen shirts he wore
when paradise did return good morning I
[Music]
love a classic like beachy white linen
t-shirt on a guy like some like khaki
colored pants it's just such a good look
it's a great look what's your favorite
look on a guy you know we don't talk
fashion enough on this show obviously
obviously number two another crucem
closing moment but this time we're
moving on to the bachelor when Chris
talks to Colton about his virginity on
the trailer for the new season of The
Bachelor you could lose your virginity
this week sexual intimacy is a big part
of any relationship
that's a sit down literally they sit
down on some stairs and they get into it
I can't wait to watch that and our
number one Chris Harrison moment of 2018
it's two words everybody holy holy holy
[Music]
that moment with Chris emerging from the
darkness as Colton storms off from the
cameras which by the way he told me
Colton was strobing away from him
because he was trying to talk to him
there were things that led to me having
to talk to him that forced the jump and
you've gotta watch out we're talking to
Chris Harrison they don't know all right
everybody what do you love about Chris
tell me is your favorite version of
Chris Harrison
sit down drama bring me those tears or
is it dry humor or is it let me call you
out cuz he does it all I am so happy and
Mary
to be celebrating the holidays with all
of you I sincerely hope that everybody
is having a great holiday whatever
you're celebrating with your families
with your friends with your loved ones
and you know what no matter who you're
with know that I love you and I'm so
grateful for this time with you guys and
let me know it what your favorite moment
of Chris Harrison was from 2018 there's
a lot of issues going on right now or
you think about your moment I'd love to
hambo
all right everybody we're gonna end the
way that every good show should end as I
learned growing up doing community
theater with a song here for the last
time in 2018 is a musical version of our
journey with GC Colton's taking off his
shirt and the women in reply you win
yelling I am a virgin
[Music]
watching you call this off you are a
liar that's low it premieres next month
and we will have roses
duh shallow
[Music]